hi Ethan how are you thanks for taking
the call Dave sure how can I help I got
a real got a real estate question for
you
some 22 years old debt-free and make
about sixty a year
I'm currently saving up for my first
house my question is would it be wise to
kind of use my first house is like a
rental property as well I live near a
college town I can pick up a
three-bedroom two-bathroom at 140 tsch
would it be smart to go ahead and like
bring it out to two college kids to
build equity this early in the game or
while you live there yeah you're gonna
live in like one of the bedrooms and
rent out two bedrooms yeah I mean I live
in the garage if they let me
okay I've written out three bedrooms you
know okay all right and you're gonna put
this on a 15 year fixed where the
payment with no rent coming in is less
than 1/4 of your take-home pay yeah like
if it's a worst-case scenario if it's
not rented out I just have a mortgage
payment essentially and best-case
scenario is they built equity for me
well best-case scenario is you would
make more money than the payment cost
you and that's not building equity
you're you're building the equity
they're not building equity for you
you're just collecting income as what
amounts to and you're gonna look forward
to do that because you're 22 and single
and having a bunch of roommates is not a
big problem and you're putting down you
know you have your emergency fund and
you're debt-free and you're putting down
a down payment yes sir I don't have the
the 20% saved up quite yet but I'll be
there in probably twelve months okay if
you're putting it on a 15-year fixed or
the payment is less than 1/4 of your
take-home pay with no rent income then
yeah I would do this because you would
buy that house anyway and on top of that
you're gonna get rental income on top of
that you got the income which gives you
you know that's just gravy on the
biscuit at that point that's just extra
money coming in but don't do the deal if
the only way the deal the numbers fit is
if you get rental income because you may
get in there and decide you don't want
screw with
because it could be a real hassle matter
of fact you're probably gonna learn a
whole lot as you rent to college
students as roommates
you're going to learn a lot about human
beings and you know you're gonna learn
to screen your renters very very
carefully they live in your home and
they cause problems if you don't put the
right ones in there and the good ones
are the best
best thing that ever happened to you so
you know you'll learn you'll get all of
that working in there